Hagamos algunos ejemplos más de resolución de
ecuaciones. Veremos que estas ecuaciones requieren
algunos pasos más de los que hicimos en el último
video, pero lo divertido de esto es que hay más de
una forma de hacerlo. Siempre que realicemos pasos
válidos, siempre que hagamos cualquier cosa en
el lado izquierdo y la hagamos también en el lado
derecho, vamos a avanzar en la dirección correcta
o no deberíamos obtener una respuesta incorrecta.
Así que hagamos un par de estos problemas. El
primero dice -lo reescribiré: 1.3 por x - 0.7 por
x = 12. Bueno, aquí lo primero que mi instinto me
lleva a hacer es unir estos dos términos, porque
tengo 1.3 de algo menos 0.7 de ese mismo algo.
Esta es la misma variable: si tengo 1.3 manzanas
menos 0.7 manzanas, bueno, ¿por qué no restarle
0.7 a 1.3? Y obtendremos (1.3 - 0.7)x o manzanas,
o como sea que le llamemos a esta variable, es
igual a 12. Podrían darse cuenta de que hicimos lo
inverso de la propiedad distributiva, factorizamos
una x, pero la forma en que mi cabeza piensa en
ello es que tengo 1.3 de algo menos 0.7 de algo,
eso será igual a 1.3 - 0.7 de ese algo que es x;
y por supuesto 1.3 - 0.7 = 0.6 por x de ese algo,
es igual a 12. Ahora, eso se parece a uno de
los problemas que hicimos en un video anterior.
Tenemos un coeficiente multiplicado por x que es
igual a algún otro número. Bueno, dividamos ambos
lados de esta ecuación entre ese coeficiente,
dividamos ambos lados entre 0.6, entonces en el
lado izquierdo simplemente quedará una x, x es
igual a, ¿cuánto es 12 ÷ 0.6? 0.6 cabe en 12,
agreguemos algunos ceros después del punto
decimal, eso es lo mismo que dividir 120 entre 6:
120 / 6, 2 por 6 es igual a12, restamos el
resultado es 0, 6 cabe en 0 cero veces. Entonces
esto es igual a 20, 12 ÷ 0.6 = 20. Y podemos
verificarlo: sustituyamos 1.3 x 20 - 0.7 x 20,
verifiquemos que sea igual a 12, así que usemos
la calculadora para que no tengamos que confiar
en mis cálculos, de modo que 1.3 x 20 = 26, esta
parte es igual a 26, y luego 0.7 x 20, no necesito
una calculadora para eso, es igual a 14, 26 -14
= 12, así que es correcto, tenemos la respuesta
correcta para esta ecuación: x es igual a 20.
Hagamos este de aquí: 5x - 3x + 2 = 1. Esto parece
muy complicado y cuando algo parezca abrumador
simplemente sigamos los pasos que nos ayuden a
simplificar la ecuación, y con el tiempo siempre
que sigamos pasos válidos iremos progresando. Así
que lo primero que haremos será distribuir este -1
aquí, entonces esto es lo mismo que 5x - 3x - 2,
de acuerdo. Acabo de aplicar la propiedad
distributiva en 3x y en 2, este es -1 por 3 x + 2,
entonces es -1 x 3 ± 1 por 2, o -3x - 2 y esto es
igual a 1. Ahora tengo 5 de algo menos 3 de ese
mismo algo, entonces eso es igual a 2 de ese algo:
5x - 3x es 2x, 5 - 3 es 2, y luego tengo - 2,
es igual a 1. Y ahora nos gustaría tener la forma
de 2x o tener algo multiplicado x y que eso sea
igual a algo, así que queremos deshacernos de este
-2 del lado izquierdo. La mejor manera de hacerlo
es sumar 2 a ambos lados, de modo que vamos a
sumar 2 en el lado izquierdo, si lo hago del lado
izquierdo tengo que hacerlo del lado derecho, +2
en el lado derecho. Estos dos números se cancelan
y obtendremos 2x = 1 + 2, que es igual a 3. Ahora
podemos dividir ambos lados entre 2 y obtenemos
que x = 3/2, y dejo que ustedes verifiquen que
esta es la respuesta correcta. Déjenme trazar
una línea por aquí para que nuestro trabajo no se
vea desordenado, aunque esto podría parecer aún
más desordenado. Aquí tenemos que resolver para
encontrar ese. Fíjense que tenemos una fracción y
dos términos de s, ¿cómo resolvemos esto? Bueno,
hagámoslo de la misma manera: tenemos 1 por s,
podemos ver esto como 3/8 s = 5/6, podríamos
ver esto como 1 multiplicado por s menos 3/8
s = 5/6. Podríamos factorizar una s, quizás lo
hagamos así, lo factorizaremos del lado izquierdo,
esto es lo mismo que s (1 - 3/8) = 5/6, ¿y cuánto
es 1 - 3/8? Este 1 lo podemos reescribir como 8/8,
eso es 1, entonces esto es lo mismo que 8/8 -
3/8 = 5/8 multiplicado por s. Podemos cambiar
el orden de la multiplicación: 5/8s = 5/6, y
podríamos resolver directamente desde acá. Si
tenemos 1 de algo menos 3/8 de ese algo es como
tener 8/8 de ese algo menos 3/8 de ese algo,
y nos van a quedar 5/8 de ese algo. Ahora para
encontrar el valor de s podemos multiplicar ambos
lados por el inverso de este coeficiente, entonces
multiplicamos 8/5 x 5/8 s. Si lo hacemos del lado
izquierdo tenemos que hacerlo del lado derecho:
8/5 multiplicamos 8 sobre 5 para que estos se
cancelen y estos se cancelen, y nos quedamos con s
es igual a, esto es 1, es igual, a, bueno, podemos
dividir el numerador y el denominador entre 5 y
también podemos dividir este numerador entre 2
y este denominador entre 2, y el resultado es 4/3,
s = 4/3. Resolvamos uno más de estos aquí. Tenemos
5 (q - 7) / 12 = 2/3. Déjenme escribir esto, y
podríamos reescribir esto como 5/12 (q - 7) = 2/3,
y lo que quiero hacer en este video es mostrarles
que podemos resolverlo de dos formas diferentes,
en tanto que realicemos operaciones válidas
deberíamos obtener el mismo resultado. De modo que
la primera forma en que lo haremos es multiplicar
ambos lados de esta ecuación por el inverso de
5/12. Entonces voy a multiplicar ambos lados por
12/5, porque queremos deshacernos de 5/12 del lado
izquierdo, que hace que se vea un poco complicado.
Lo multiplicamos por 12 / 5 porque estos se van a
cancelar, el 5 y el 5 se cancelan y el 12 y el
12 se cancelan, así que el lado izquierdo de
nuestra ecuación se convierte en q - 7 es igual al
lado derecho 2/3 por 5/12. Si dividimos 12 entre
3 obtenemos 4, y dividimos 3 entre 3 y obtenemos
1, entonces 2 por 4 es igual a 8 sobre 5. Y ahora
podemos sumar 7 a ambos lados de esta ecuación,
así que sumamos 7 ambos lados de esta ecuación,
estos dos 7 se cancelan y ese fue el objetivo
de sumar 7, y nos queda que q = 8/5 + 7,
o podríamos escribir 8/5 más, 7 se puede escribir
como 35/5, de modo que esto va a ser igual a,
el denominador es 5, 8 + 35 = 43. Entonces
nuestra respuesta, resolviendo de esta manera,
es que q = 43/5. Y dije que lo haríamos
de dos maneras. Hagámoslo de otra manera,
así que déjenme escribir el mismo problema: 5 (q -
7) / 12 = 2/3. Vamos a deshacernos del 12 primero,
déjenme multiplicar ambos lados de esta ecuación
por 12. No me gusta este 12 aquí, así que vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados por 12, estos se cancelan
y del lado izquierdo nos queda 5 (q - 7) = 2/3
(12). Esto es lo mismo que 24 / 3. Déjenme
escribirlo así: 2 / 3 por 12 / 1 es igual a, si,
dividimos 2 / 3 = 4; dividimos 3 / 3 y obtenemos
1 = 8, entonces 5 (q - 7) = 8, y luego en lugar de
dividir ambos lados entre 5, lo que nos acercaría
bastante a lo que estábamos haciendo aquí, vamos a
distribuir este 5. Sólo quiero mostrar que podemos
hacerlo de múltiples formas válidas. Entonces 5
por q = 5q, 5 por -7 = 35, es igual a 8, 5q - 35
= 8. Ahora si queremos deshacernos de este -35,
o de este 35 negativo, la mejor manera de hacerlo
es sumar 35 a ambos lados, lo hacemos así para que
estos se cancelen y nos quedamos con 5q = 8 + 35,
que es igual a 43. Ahora podemos multiplicar ambos
lados de esta ecuación por 1/5, que es lo mismo
que dividir ambos lados entre 5. Estos se cancelan
y nos queda q = 43 / 5. Así que hay muchas
formas de solucionar estos problemas, siempre que
realicemos pasos válidos obtendremos la respuesta
correcta. Y les dejo a ustedes verificar que esta
sea realmente la respuesta correcta para q, este
es el valor de q que satisface esta ecuación.
Hagamos un problema verbal: "Jade está en el
centro y sólo tiene 10 dólares para llegar a
casa. Los taxis cobran 75 centavos por milla, pero
hay un cargo inicial de 2.35 dólares adicionales.
Escribe una fórmula y úsala para calcular cuántas
millas puede recorrer con su dinero". Muy bien,
de modo que el costo total de un viaje en taxi
será igual al cargo inicial que es de 2.35 dólares
más los 75 centavos por milla multiplicado por
el número de millas. Digamos que m es igual a
las millas que recorre, la letra m es igual
a las millas recorridas, así que esta es la
ecuación. Sabemos que sólo tiene 10 dólares para
llegar a casa, entonces su costo tiene que ser de
10 dólares, el costo total tiene que ser igual a
10 dólares, así que 10 = 2.35 + 0.75 m. Así que,
¿cómo calculamos m o el número de millas que Jade
puede recorrer? Bueno, podemos deshacernos del
2.35 en el lado derecho restando esa cantidad de
ambos lados de esta ecuación, así que hagámoslo,
restamos -2.35 de ambos lados: estos se
cancelan, ese era el punto. En el lado izquierdo,
¿cuánto es 10 - 2.35? 10 - 2 = 8, 10 - 2.3 =
7.7, así que el resultado es 7.65. Comprobémoslo:
10 - 2.35 = 7.65 y eso es igual a 0.75 m. Esto es
esto y esto es esto, luego estos dos números se
cancelan. Ahora para calcular m, podemos dividir
ambos lados entre 0.75, entonces, si dividimos
este lado entre 0.75 tenemos que hacerlo del
lado izquierdo también: 0.75. Esto se cancela,
así que del lado derecho nos quedamos sólo con una
m y en el lado izquierdo, usamos la calculadora,
y tenemos que 7.65 ÷ 0.75 = 10.2 m, es igual a
10.2, por lo que Jade puede viajar 10.2 millas.